-Seth, before we get started,
can I say something?
-Please.
-You have Amanda Seales
on the show, right?
I was just backstage with her,
and she told me I was rude to
her the first two times we met.
She actually said
I was an asshole.
-Okay.
This is our stand-up comedian
who's on tonight.
-So, I would like to --
Amanda, I know you can hear me!
-There are TVs
in our dressing room.
-Yeah, but I wanted her
to hear me through the wall.
Amanda, I sincerely
apologize to you in front of
all these people
and the 72 million people
that are watching
Seth Meyers right now.
I do apologize
for my rude behavior.
I don't recall it,
but if you say that happened,
I believe you.
So I do apologize.
-All right.
-I do...
[ Applause ]
I do think that's too late
to affect her set,
which is all about
what a dick you are.
[ Laughter ]
Like, she can't write a new set.
Congratulations.
You had a great morning.
-Thank you. I did.
-You were nominated
for "Black-ish."
-Nominated for "Black-ish."
-The show was
nominated, as well.
-The show was nominated.
-And "Ferdinand."
-And "Ferdinand" was nominated.
-So that's really exciting.
-Yeah, it was a great morning.
-I'm very excited.
I also -- This is exciting
for me to ask,
because my son's very young.
I've got another one on the way.
You have two, right?
-I have two.
-Your daughter finishing
college, senior in college.
-Senior in college.
-Your son waiting to hear, yes?
-Waiting to hear.
We -- My wife and I are
supposed to be empty-nesters,
but that's not gonna happen,
because my daughter
is graduating in May
and just found out the other day
that she's moving
back home after graduation.
-Okay.
-And my son has not
received his acceptance letter
to any of the colleges
that he applied to,
so he may not even
leave the house.
-Okay, gotcha.
So you're full-nesters.
-So I'm a full-nester, yeah.
So that's right where
I am right now.
-Gotcha.
-Yeah.
-I want to ask --
do you go on the college tours?
Did you go with your son?
-I did.
We only went on one.
I went to Howard University.
Yeah, that's it.
Just one.
-That's great work, man.
-He was only going
to Howard University.
That's where I went.
That's where his mother went.
That's where
his mother and I met.
-Oh, great.
-We didn't conceive him there,
but we tried to.
-Yeah.
-We tried to.
-So, no, we went to
Howard, man, because, you know,
I wanted my son to have
the black experience
that I had when I was
a student at Howard University.
And, you know, because he's been
living a black-ish experience.
-Yeah.
-And so I wanted him to
experience that.
And I took him to the school,
and he fell in love with it.
-When you walk around
on the tour,
are you a little hoping that --
Well, you've got
your son with you.
Are you a little hoping
you'll get recognized
by the other kids?
-It's a black university, Seth.
Yes, they recognize me.
-Okay, good.
-I'm good in the black markets.
-'Cause I was on
Howard University campus once,
and I couldn't get arrested.
-Yeah. Yeah, but
if you went across town
to G-Dub or Georgetown,
"Seth! Seth!"
Yeah.
-True story -- I went
to Howard University once.
You know who I
went with that I think
is one of the reasons
I did not get recognized?
-Who is it? Puff?
-Michelle Obama.
-Oh, Michelle Obama.
-Yeah.
-Oh, no. Nobody gets recognized
with Michelle Obama.
-No. I was just the
blurry outside of -- Yeah.
-What were you guys
doing there together?
-We shot something for her --
Like, an educational initiative.
-Oh, really?
-It was fantastic.
-Okay, yeah.
-When we surprised
college students --
like, she walked out
and surprised them --
people lost their minds
in a way that made
so much sense to me
once I saw it.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Especially kids that were
freshmen, 'cause you realize,
like, how young they were
when they came into --
when she came into their lives.
-Right, right.
-It was just stunning to watch.
-No, I had
the opportunity to play golf
with President Obama.
-Oh, wow.
-You know, not too long ago.
And, man, just -- It's amazing.
They had snipers
on mountain ridges.
You know, they shut
the golf course down.
It was just the president,
myself, Chris Paul,
and Michael Phelps, man,
and some of our other friends.
That's one hell of
a foursome, man.
-Now, how's your golf game?
-Oh, it's horrible.
-Okay.
-Yeah, it's horrible.
-But you still were
confident enough to golf.
-Oh, yes.
-Okay.
-Oh, no, no, no.
It's horrible only
because work gets in the way.
You know, when I'm
playing consistently --
-But you know what you're doing.
-I know what I'm doing.
-Were you more nervous
when you're golfing
with the president,
about your game?
-No, not at all, 'cause
I didn't think he could play.
-Uh-huh.
-But he can play.
And he talks
a lot of trash, man.
He talks a lot of trash.
And he was the best golfer
out of all four of us.
-Wow.
-Yeah. He took our money, and
I couldn't believe it.
I was like, "As a taxpayer,
I can't believe
you're taking this money."
He was like,
"I'm a civilian now, Anthony.
Give me the money."
But then I took Chris Paul
and Michael Phelps' money.
-All right,
so it all worked out.
-It all balanced itself out.
-Okay, that's great.